ah
I can do this I'm gonna hide my powers
and be a normal man having a normal day
hang on
starting
dumb everyone thinks they know the Man
of Steel
but you've never seen the son of Jarrell
like this before who am I
what was that Superman I'd like to
interview you for the Daily Planet uh
sorry no comment Louis these are the
newer dirt I want show them the ropes
they can help me with the story if we
break this we'll become real reporters
who is Superman Lois I know what
Superman is huh you think he's a plane
it it kind of looks like a bird my
adventures with Superman two episodes
series premiere Thursday July 6 at
midnight on Adult Swim next day on max
[Music]
oh